ce
bonjour pour commencer je vous propose
un petit jeu le siège sur lequel vous
êtes assis en ce moment imaginez que un
siège de voiture ainsi bien attachés et
vous rouler à 200 km/heure et au loin en
face de vous voyez un mur un immense mur
vous allez droit devant le chauffeur à
côté de vous inanimé
vous avez trois solutions
la première je saute par la fenêtre la
deuxième je m'accroche je ferme les yeux
et surtout je serre les fesses
la troisième solution
j'essaie de prendre le contrôle de la
voiture et d'éviter le mur quel sera
votre choix
maintenant si je vous dis que la voiture
dans laquelle vous êtes assis
c'est notre planète et nous n'en avons
qu'une
et elle fonce droit dans un mur
ensemble nous fonçons droit dans un mur
la solution sauter par la fenêtre
vous pouvez oublier il vous reste
maintenant deux solutions et ensemble je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi
c'est la troisième solution qu'il faut
retenir prendre les contrôle et éviter
le mieux avant ça je vais vous raconter
une histoire l'histoire d'un petit
garçon
un petit martiniquais qui a grandi
heureux un fort de france dans une
grande famille quatre enfants et ce
petit garçon et mais avant tout la pêche
la pêche à la rivière la pêche à la mer
avec papa les cousins les tontons son
enfance a été bercée par des magnifiques
histoires de pêche quelque chose qu'il
aimait beaucoup c'était la pêche à la
rivière il avait un petit rituel
quand il arrivait sur une rivière ils se
posaient y poser leurs affaires et avant
de sortir des lignes on prenait un petit
bout de femme un petit bout de pain
rassis si possible en envoyait dans
l'eau pour regarder ce qui se passait en
général des petits poissons venait
toucher un petit peu au bout de pain le
titiller c'est un bon signe à ce moment
là il y en avait un qui commençait à
préparer les lignes en envoyant un
deuxième petit bout de pain et petits
poissons continuer et puis un moment le
pain disparaissait l'allégro été senties
et là on lançait les lignes hélas la
pêche pouvait commencer
ce petit garçon a donc grandi en étant
percée dans des histoires de pêche il
allait se coucher la nuit avec des dés
des poissons plein la tête et il était
heureux et un jour il a dû partir loin
d'ici en france faire des études
il a intégré une école d'ingénieurs pas
facile nouvelle culture nouveaux pays
nouvelle température pas facile mais il
s'est battu il s'est battu pour
représenter son île pour représenter sa
femme il faut qu'on soit fier de lui et
il a réussi
à 23 ans diplôme d'ingénieur en poche
il savait faire voler des avions il
savait gérer des projets à plusieurs
millions d'euros
il était content fier de lui sa famille
est fière de lui tout le monde sont ils
voulaient être fier de lui et puis un
jour il est rentré en vacances en
martinique et il s'est dit je vais aller
pêcher
non c'est pas vrai d'abord il s'est dit
je veux manger un migrant de fruit à
pain parce que quand vous avez passé un
hiver en bretagne le migrant de fruit à
pain c'est important une fois rassasié
il part avec son père son petit neveu
qui est un pécheur apprentis et ils vont
dans une rivière qui connaissait bien il
arrive le petit rituel on se pose en
envoie un petit bout de pain on n'attend
rien des petits poissons qui normalement
vienne au début pour appâter un peu les
groupes rien ah le petit bout de pain se
faire emporter
il part dans le courant bon on en voit
un deuxième petit bout de pain il flotte
se laisse emporter
rien n'y a plus de poisson
bon on va essayer notre rivière ils se
déplacent deuxième rivière petit bout de
pain ouais on va changer de corte pas
sur la côte caraïbe rivière petits bouts
de pain rien hélas notre petit garçon
devenu grand a regardé son papa regardez
son petit neveu trois générations
réunies et ne comprenait pas ils ont
ressenti une profonde tristesse devant
ces rivières morte mais surtout de
l'impuissance de l'impuissance parce
qu'ils ne savaient pas quoi faire
finalement ce petit garçon c'était moi
ce choc
cette tristesse cette impuissance devant
les rivières mort de mon île je les
ressentis à 23 ans et j'étais désemparée
j'ai figé
j'ai regardé autour de moi et j'ai vu ça
les catastrophes naturelles de plus en
plus fréquentes
de plus en plus forte de la pollution
par tous l'impasse une empreinte
indélébile qu'on laisse des inégalités
entre les riches et les pauvres entre le
nord et le sud
grandissante qui poussent des millions
de gens à fuir leur pays pour essayer de
trouver une vie meilleure
des guerres des famines tout ça sur
notre petite planète
la seule que nous avons
et ce sentiment d'impuissance je me
sentais impuissant quand je parlais aux
gens autour de moi mes proches mes amis
on avait tous souvent me disais mais on
ne peut rien faire
en martinique c'est toujours la même
chose le pays est contrôlé par des
grands groupes
au niveau mondial c'est la même chose
c'est les mêmes politiques qui décident
si les mêmes grandes entreprises qui
décident
on ne peut rien faire ce discours
revenait souvent alors j'ai décidé de
partir j'ai décidé de voyager de mme
exporter et d'aller retrouver quelque
part cette force pour éviter ça la fin
de la civilisation notre destruction
parce que d'autres avant nous ont eu des
problèmes et non pas forcément su les
surmonter et ont disparu
alors j'ai voyagé je suis parti j'ai
vécu dans plusieurs pays plusieurs
continents l'australie le burkina faso
le canada la france la martinique le
mexique est partout j'ai rencontré des
gens je suis rentré en contact avec des
gens qui vivaient les mêmes problèmes
que nous à notre échelle et ses jambes
ont transmis une force par exemple au
burkina faso j'ai travaillé avec des
productrices de beurre de karité des
femmes extrêmement forte qui depuis des
siècles et des siècles font du beurre de
karité naturels biologiques et qui
aujourd'hui se retrouvent en concurrence
avec le real l'occitane toutes ces
grandes boîtes internationale et qui
finalement n'arrivent plus à vendre leur
beurre de karité autour d'elle en
afrique parce que l'afrique se met à
acheter des produits européens
et ces femmes mères de famille
la plupart illettrés on leur demande de
faire des sites web de faire du
marketing pour prouver que leur beurre
de karité qu'elles font depuis des
siècles est meilleur que les autres
alors est ce que vous pensez qu elles
vont baisser les bras et a arrêté non
non elles ont une force saison ou
puissance de continuer et c'est cette
puissance laquelle seront transmises au
canada j'ai rencontré al gore l'ancien
vice-président américain qui a fondé son
ong réalité climatique dont le but est
de faire prendre conscience aux gens de
l'urgence des changements climatiques et
de l'urgence de l'action et lui aussi
m'a transmis cette force lui aussi m'a
emmené avec lui et je suis devenu
ambassadeur de son ong
tous ces gens là que j'ai rencontré
finalement vous redonner confiance en
moi et ont fait qu'aujourd'hui j'ai
décidé de rentrer invente inique et
d'essayer de faire avancer mon pays et
de transmettre cette puissance et cette
force que l'on m'a donnée la bonne
nouvelle c'est que j'ai rencontré des
fous si on veut dire mais des gens qui
partagent ma passion et ma vision est
ensemble on a créé une entreprise green
technology une entreprise martiniquaise
dont le but est de promouvoir
l'utilisation saine de l'énergie moins
d'énergie plus d'énergies renouvelables
pourquoi l'énergie parce que l'énergie
c'est un enjeu clé en 20 minutes
vous êtes vous déjà posé la question de
l'impact d'un plein d'essence
vous arrivez à la station service vous
vous garez vous tendez les clés aux
pompistes et vous demandez le plein s'il
vous plaît 60 70 euros dans votre porte
monnaie ça vous le savez une bonne
centaine de kilogrammes de co2 émis près
de votre domicile près de l'école de vos
enfants quelque part sur l'île des gaz
nocifs etc
mais ce pétrole il a fallu le faire
venir ici c'est plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres dans des super tanker au
dessus de l'océan au dessus de la mer
des caraïbes de nos beaux récifs
coralliens plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres dans des pipelines
travers des pays entiers à côté de fans
de villages où vivent des familles comme
vous et moi ce sont des puits de pétrole
ce sont des multinationales qui
investissent dans des pays en
développement ce sont des guerres causés
par ce pétrole on peut même dire que ce
sont des attentats les centaines de
morts de paris du 13 novembre dernier ne
sont pas morts à cause d'un dieu son
bord pour du pouvoir pour de l'argent et
pour du pétrole
c'est tout ça comporte quand on fait le
plein d'essence alors si maintenant on
avait tous une voiture électrique
alimenté par des panneaux solaires
si maintenant notre maison est alimenté
par des panneaux solaires
et c'est faisable pour 90 euros par mois
pouvait avoir des panneaux
photovoltaïques sur votre maison et
prendre votre autonomie par rapport à
tout ce système qui dépend du pétrole
nous avons le choix c'est faisable
maintenant il n'ya pas que dans
l'énergie qu'on a du pétrole
notre mode de consommation comment ça se
fait quand vint teennick on mange autant
de pommes et de raison comment ça se
fait qu'on 26 nique on mange autant de
produits procès c'est suremballés qu'ils
ont traversées de l'atlantique ou même
toute la planète pour arriver chez nous
alors quand on vit dans un sur une île
où la nature est luxuriante où à
longueur d'année on a des fruits et des
légumes de qualité et où surtout on a
des agriculteurs des artisans locaux qui
font la promotion de ces choses-là
visité deux entreprises qui ont été
créées il ya moins d'un an
la boxe nature une entreprise créée par
deux jeunes femmes et qui vous livre
chez vous ou à votre travail
une box comme et 10 rempli de fruits et
légumes locaux de qualité biologique
vais juste un clic à faire sur internet
une autre entreprise créée par une femme
là encore les jardins de ol c'est une
jeune fille qui a travaillé avec son
père dans l'agriculture et qui
aujourd'hui a décidé d'amener ce service
aux gens encore livraison fruits légumes
du jus des marmelades et confitures des
choses comme ça on a le choix
le choix est entre nos mains
noël est dans quatre jours qui dans la
salle n'a pas encore tous ces cadeaux
vous me rassurer je ne suis pas le seul
maintenant nous avons quatre jours pour
trouver ces derniers cadeaux entre temps
on doit travailler on doit s'occuper des
enfants et on doit préparer la réception
de la famille etc
alors on peut quelque part dans ces
quatre jours trouvé le temps d'aller
dans un de nos fameux centres
commerciaux avoir du mal à se garer
prendre des embouteillages se battre à
moitié pour trouver les derniers
produits payer quelque chose de trop
cher pour finalement ne pas vraiment
être satisfait du résultat de l'impact
que le cadre aura sur la personne ou
alors si on se posait si on
réfléchissait et qu'on essayait de faire
quelque chose de différent par exemple
on pourrait offrir du temps du temps de
baby sitting à votre soeur du temps une
après midi avec votre mère on pourrait
offrir quelque chose à manger cuisine
est un bon petit plat avant quelqu'un
que vous aimez ça lui fera plaisir
vous pouvez offrir de l'artisanat local
un produit le cas vous pouvez offrir une
expérience un massage une soirée au
restaurant on a le choix
on n'est pas obligé d'aller forcément
dans les mêmes magasins faire les mêmes
choix de consommation que nous avons
fait l'année dernière
si je résume on veut consommer moins
d'énergie et plus d'énergies
renouvelables on vous consommez moins de
biens de consommation en off on peut
promouvoir aussi les changes
la seconde main etc et finalement on
veut promouvoir l'artisanat local et
l'agriculture locale déjà sur réalisé
trois choses là on commence à se sentir
plus libre plus libre de ses choix plus
moins attachés a insisté
on commence à avoir plus de temps je
vous le dis parce que je le fais au fur
et à mesure et c'est vrai on a plus de
temps plus d'argent une meilleure
qualité de vie maintenant qu'est ce
qu'il nous reste pour réellement éviter
ça éviter que notre voiture
notre planète fonce dans le mur il faut
en parler
il faut créer quelque chose il faut
ramener du monde avec nous parce que
tout seul à 23 ans devant cette rivière
vite je me suis senti impuissant mais
rencontrant du monde qui vivaient les
mêmes choses ensemble on s'est sentis
puissant et voilà la clé la clé c'est de
s'organiser et ensemble nous pourrons
faire changer les choses
comment s'organiser il faut parler il
faut faire passer le message
on a des outils internet qui sont
fabuleux pour ça et raconter nos
histoires qui dotent que nous c'est lui
le faire mieux en martinique
nous sommes un peuple qui s'est bâtie
sur les histoires sur l'imaginaire rival
vient de nous en parler
si je vous dis est cuit y investit qu
est ce que la cour d'or non la cour n'a
donc pas la courneuve en plus la cour
s'est réveillé et veut faire changer les
choses
avant de vous laisser je vais vous
raconter une histoire que l'on m'a
apprise au canada c'est une légende
amérindienne la légende du colibri un
jour dans une forêt il ya eu un grand
incendie de forêt tous les animaux pris
de panique ont fui lincendie courant et
laissant derrière eux un incendie et
alors qu'il courait ils ont fait un
petit colibri passer au dessus d'eux en
sens inverse
aller au plus près des flammes et une
fois arrivés près des flammes crachez
deux petites gouttes d'eau qu'il avait
dans son bec sur les flammes et repartir
chercher de l'eau alors au deuxième
passage du colibri des animaux se sont
arrêtés ils l'ont regardé l'heure dite
colibri qui sont kafala aux fous ah oui
les attend les légendes amérindiennes
les animaux parlent créole c'est normal
donc se soit arrêté mais petit colibri
sais tu penses vraiment qu'avec des deux
gouttes d'eau tu va éteindre l'incendié
ça ne sert à rien ce que tu fais et le
colibri s'est arrêté il les a regardés
et leur a dit je sais mais je fais ma
part je sais mais je fais ma part et la
légende amérindienne s'arrête là parce
que ça à nous d'écrire la suite c'est à
nous de décider si les autres animaux
vous continuent à fuir
où vont aller prêter main-forte au
colibri ma grande idée pour ma petite
île la voilà la martinique c'est l'île
aux fleurs soit ayant des colibris
chacun d'entre nous tous ici dans cette
salle
soyons à petit colibri qui va faire sa
part pour faire changer les choses et
vous verrez que nous nous sentirons plus
tout seul mais que nous allons créer
quelque chose qui ira loin
antoine de saint-exupéry et d'autres ont
dit nous n'héritons pas de la terre de
nos ancêtres nous l'empruntons à nos
enfants
aujourd'hui notre terre va mal
aujourd'hui notre terre fonce dans un
mur
si demain
nous voulons faire changer les choses si
demain nous voulons que nos enfants et
que leurs enfants puissent aller pêcher
dans les mêmes rivière rouge et pêcher
ou d'autres vous d'autres d'entre vous
empêchez et trouvé des poissons et
trouve une planète en bonne santé
c'est aujourd'hui qu'il nous faut
changer nous n'héritons pas de la terre
de nos ancêtres nous l'empruntons à nos
enfants
merci
oui
rambo